[Music]
what's up guys I'm gonna be showing you
a very afk low requirement money making
guide so what we're gonna be doing we're
be cutting Jade's and opals okay so the
Jade's right now are making a little bit
higher profit than the opals but they're
about the same but the Jade's require
only 13 crafting and the opals require
only one crafting so that's I mean the
same profits for a low-level so I'm
gonna buy a hundred of each and cut them
and then sell them and then show you
guys all you need to do this is your
chisel and then your opals or Jade's
okay
and so you'd click it cut select all and
that's how you do it so I'll be back
when I have a cut a hundred of each
alright I'm back so I cut about 81
hopefuls and 68 Jade's and it takes
about two minutes to cut a hundred so
keep that in mind and then go to my
history so was it so sold opals for 233
go back to exchange so the old opals for
233 go back to here we sold Jade's for
525 525
okay so we look on here so we sold the
opals for so we basically made 18 19 K
and we bought for 8 K so that's about 10
K profit and the Jade's right now we
only we only made about 3 K so that's
actually not worth it right now so I
would stick to doing the opals which is
only one crafting so 10 K in two minutes
so 60 divided by 2 is 30 30 times 10 K
so 300 K so 3 WK an hour with doing the
opals and that requires only one crafty
and it's pretty afk so yeah so thanks
for watching guys stay tuned from the
next video